it says for each of the following
triangles
write down the ratios for each of the
given angles okay
so there's our first one i'm just going
to roughly draw it
you've got theater up there in the top
corner
and that's an f sorry it's a bit of a
shabby f i'm trying
all right now they want us to know okay
what's sine and cos and tan
of this angle up here okay and it's
super easy
watch sine theta cos theta
uh tan theta yeah is it like a trick to
do that changes
well one of the helpful tricks is to
know
what like remember how i talked about
all of these labelings right
so if you can nail those the rest of it
just kind of falls out i'll show you
what i mean
i'm talking about drawings awesome oh
jordan on my thoughts
yeah you should don't worry you'll get
the hang of it trust me
after you've written a few hundred
thousand of them it's second nature
okay now i'm gonna label all of these
sides one two three
in relation to theta okay the easiest
one's the hypotenuse because it's always
the same which one's the high point
it's f good it's opposite the right
angle it's the longest side
so i'll just call this one hypotenuse
okay
um e over here it's um
it's on the other side from theta right
so it's opposite
okay and that leaves d which is right
next to the angle
so that's adjacent okay so
i would say sine theta i'm going back to
sakato now right
sine is opposite of hypotenuse opposite
on hypotenuse e on f
that's it that's all it's equal to
simple
okay um cause is soccer
c-a-h adjacent on hypotenuse
adjacent on hypotenuse d on f
okay by the way please note um the order
matters right like
e on f is not the same as
f on e makes a big deal right so it's um
it's sakatoa not not
shakatoa no the order really matters
okay wouldn't be the same
correct yeah because fractions you know
for example one over two
is not equal to two over one totally
different things
last one ten theta why is this sokka toa
opposite
on adjacent opposite on adjacent
e over d that's it it's really simple
isn't it
here's what it looks like and theta is
in the bottom right hand corner
and then you've got these two legs
now it says
write the trigonometric ratio which must
be used
in order to find the value of the
pro-numeral
in each of the following triangles that
was a mouthful okay
um let's start with right the
trigonometric ratio which must use so
we're either going to have sine
or cos or tan that's going to be the
answer
one of them right depending on the
information we've got
so look at this right you got two sides
right and the question is
which two sides have you got um 15 it's
opposite the right angle it's the
longest side so that's clearly
the hypotenuse right over here
hold on hold on i don't have this side
over here
what i do have over here is opposite
right
so you can see that's the pen you need
here's the equation you would write we
already worked out you don't need
content it's signed that we're after
right so you'd write
sine theta equals opposite hypotenuse
that's 12 on 15.
you can simplify that fraction right
what does it simplify to
what's the common factor it's going to
be the common factor is three so it's
four fifths
okay now reach for your calculator now
okay i'm going to get miner
the reason i knew that psi would be the
one i wanted
is because the two sides that i've got
right in relation to theta right
which sides are there right there's this
opposite adjacent hypotenuse but
that's three i've only got two of them
right and the answer is i look i'm like
well the 12
is opposite theta so it's the opposite
side
well because i don't know what it is so
there's no point saying that's the
adjacent side because
i don't know its value so i can't work
with it okay whereas
i do know what these are so i can write
this down
okay now having done this okay you can
see sine is sort of in the middle
of your calculator now just above sign
above the button it looks like this
okay now this is so important it's
actually worth drawing the little button
here
and telling you what this is all about
okay that thing that's above sign
some people say this but uh it's a
negative one
and the way you read this is this is
called sine
inverse okay
so the easiest way to explain this is
you know how to
square something right there's x squared
well the inverse of squaring something
is to undo
this way you take the square root okay
if i had 5 and then i squared it you get
25 if i take the square root i come back
to my original number
okay so what you've got here is sine of
some number the angle that i'm after
is equal to four fifths okay sign of
that number so to
undo that here's what i'm going to write
theta equals
sine inverse of four-fifths this line is
really important and it's a bit
weird so make sure you write it down
okay
you cannot skip this is vitally
important
yes what have i done i want to get theta
on its own
okay so to get rid of sine i use this
side inverse idea
okay so this is what i'm going to do i'm
going to go to my calculator
obviously because it's above the button
i'll hold down i'll press shift
okay shift press the side button and
you'll see
the brackets appear this will come up on
your calculator
right so what you're going to punch in
is
four over five or 0.8 if you're lying
so you press shift sign right and then
this would come up
so now you can type in the fraction and
then you can close the bracket
all right now when you press equals what
happens
i'm just gonna write that many okay now
what does this tell you
what does this tell you um let's just
round it off to the nearest
unit the nearest unit so it's
approximately 53 degrees
okay and what this means is that if you
drew a triangle
right and if it was right angle and if
you measured it properly and carefully
you made this side 12 you made this side
15
who knows what the other side is okay
you go find out by pythagoras if you
want to
but the point is that when you draw that
triangle right
this angle over here is going to be 53
degrees
it will always be 53 degrees it can't
possibly equal anything else there's no
way you can redraw the triangle
it's always going to be equal to this
okay it's a little bit like
okay if someone's measured my next
circumference
and they've measured my arm length okay
my finger lengths are going to be
such and such there's nothing else that
it's it's
conclusive okay so all this information
over here
it's conclusive this is the angle you
end up with and in fact
i'd actually love you guys to give this
a go because 12
and 15 that's not too long you might
have a ruler there or you can borrow one
off
me okay there's a 15 centimeter ruler
okay
i want you to actually draw this out and
then i can give you a projector i have
some here
right and sure enough you will measure
and it'll be 53 degrees
you'll get your ruler okay now
um measure out your 12 centimeters now
i'm just going to say you know
suppose that's 12 centimeters okay
you've measured that that's great
okay now rather than draw the next one
the 15 centimeters the problem with it
is
i don't know like is it up here or over
there
what's the length that's going to be
right so here's the way i would
encourage you to do it
do the bottom one now you don't know how
long it is it's no problem that's okay
just draw it really long right now just
just
keep going longer than you need to okay
then here's the trick
you know that here's your right angle
okay and your other side is going to be
here or here or here or something like
that
okay so what you do is place your point
up here
and then rotate it like this until you
get to 15 centimeters on your ruler
okay so i'll show you again so for
example i'm like okay suppose i'm here
and i'm like it's not 15.
it's it's 11 or 13 or something like
that so i keep moving i keep moving i
keep moving until ah
i've got 15 centimeters now and that's
when you joined it up
okay and then you can get rid of all
these extra bits
and you'll have a 15 centimeters that's
perfect
you'll have your right angle and then
you can get your protractor out
and whack them in here